hello hello hello it's time that we
revisit the inside of our own minds
there are more connections in a single
square centimeter of human brain tissue
then there are stars in our galaxy in a
universe is infinitely more of us than
we will ever notice and you are
unexamined daily experience of life
offers very little to suggest that this
is the case today I'm joined by someone
who can hopefully help us map out
exactly where we're going
why it is the case that we don't notice
the nature of our own minds day to day
and how to work around it
Jeff Warren is a meditation teacher and
a writer he's the co-author of
meditation for fidgety skeptics with Dan
Harris who is an American news anchor
that very famously broke down and had a
panic attack live on air Dan then went
on a journey of meditation and Jeff was
a big part of that journey
now I've wanted to get Jeff on for as
long as I can remember and his schedule
is absolutely manic I first discovered
him on Joe Rogan's podcast and then read
his and Dan's book subsequently after
that I'm also now rereading waking up by
Sam Harris which is an absolutely
fantastic exploration into the sense of
self the nature of our own consciousness
and meditation and spirituality without
religion so it was very timely for me to
sit down with Jeff he gives us a lovely
breakdown of why we should be concerned
about exploring our own consciousness as
he calls it interpersonal hygiene the
meditation practice which everyone
should be doing as often as they're
washing themselves and yeah it was it
was really eye-opening Jeff's obviously
an incredibly experienced guy in this
field and I felt like I learned a lot as
someone who's read into it quite a bit
already
so hopefully you do as well enjoy
[Music]
mr. Jeff Warren welcome to modern wisdom
how are you sir
good nice that nice to be on Chris
fantastic to hear from you so for the
listeners at home who don't know who you
are
could you give us a little bit of a
background to yourself please yeah sure
well I I started out as a journalist I
was working for the Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation writing scripts
for a kind of big Current Affair show
over in Canada and I was you know
interested in ideas that kind of became
the ideas person for that show where I
was doing a lot of kind of big picture
interviews was really interested in
science in particular and neuroscience
and I had a literature background but
got really into the brain stuff my
brothers are neuroscientists illegal
lots of talks and I ended up getting
into consciousness the whole mystery of
the mind and how the mind works and I
wrote a book called the head trip which
is sort of about the neuroscience where
the neuroscience meets our experience
like how and what these shifting states
of consciousness mean for us
you know waking sleeping and dreaming
and the different variations and
iterations and through that I got into
meditation and then that kind of ended
up changing my life and I ended up
really going kind of deep on the
meditation path and just spending all my
time practicing and going as many
retreats as I could and eventually found
a really great teacher in this guy shins
and Jung and he encouraged me to start
teaching myself I started a community of
practitioners in Toronto called the
consciousness explorers club in 2011 and
that grew really quickly and it had sort
of a unique way in which we approach the
whole subject of exploring the mind and
started teaching and eventually just
came out with a book with Dan Harris
called meditation for fidgety skeptics
which is sort of a kind of no [ __ ]
guide to what really goes on in a
practice why it's helpful where it's
maybe not helpful what are the stumbling
blocks that prevent people from getting
into it the common challenges that you
hear and where some of the best
practices for addressing that and it's
sort of a road trip as well and since
that happened it kind of just opened me
up now to a larger demographic so I'm
doing lots of podcast
like these and I have various programs
and starting to roll out around around
practice that would be a bit of an
overview
that's fascinating so it sounds like a
real trajectory from where you started I
absolutely love the name consciousness
explorers club but that is that's a
[ __ ] club that I want to be a part of
just have to be conscious to be a member
nice so very very low requirements for
the members and not even you can maybe
expand it out to the nonhuman world to
throw a few cetaceans in there some
Ravens Ravens are very skillful at
certain mind moves they say so I would
absolutely go to a consciousness
explorers club for dogs fact that sounds
not far off my Valhalla so yeah that
would be a that would be a good way to
spend an afternoon
and so you've touched upon one of the
words that I really want to focus in on
today it's a big question but can you
try and explain why people should
explore that own consciousness why
should they be bothered yeah I mean
there are so many responses to that I
guess then maybe the most obvious one is
you're already doing it anyway you know
being human means that you are living in
a particular way you're creating certain
habits of mind most of us just do this
unconsciously and whatever habits emerge
or the habits we're living with and
often some of those habits can be very
you know unhelpful to us will cause a
lot of challenges exploring your
consciousness means basically just
beginning to be deliberate about how
you're living your days about the way
your existing but the habits of mind and
body and heart that you're reinforcing
so I would say it's the beginning of
living a more awake and intentional and
deliberate life and that it's a path
that leads unquestionably to more of a
centered life less suffering more
meaning and fulfillment I mean it
doesn't mean it's an easy road but that
certainly therein lies sanity connection
all these things and and even to say
even in a bigger
than that what I'm really talking about
is practice and practice is about at a
very fundamental level choosing how you
in particular want to live this life
what are the qualities that are
important to you what are the things
that you want out of your life you can
choose practices and explorations you
will that help you make these things
happen and I mean I think that's I can't
imagine what else you would want to do
it's such a good point there's a couple
of sam harris quotes that I'm going to
smarter throughout this and try and get
some of your feedback on but in
something that he's very recently
released he actually says that most of
us spend our lives learning to live and
I think that it would appear that this
introspective work is discovering your
own path of how to live would you say
that's fair I would say that's
absolutely fair I mean we say the
consciousness Explorers Club are one of
the taglines I like is being human takes
practice and yeah you know you can just
go on autopilot and go totally
unconscious but where do you end up you
know maybe some of us with the absolute
where our decks are stacked we had
phenomenal genes we had an incredibly
healthy secure upbringing we have all
the circumstances in the world of
unfolded for us in external way
perfectly maybe then you can go on
autopilot and you can just everything
will just sort of work out I don't
perfect stole them sort of thing perfect
store my own doubt that happens for some
people you know I those people wow
they're lucky as hell for me I had to do
some major course correction and it
wasn't it wasn't optional you know it
was sort of like do-or-die mandatory it
was mandatory
exactly so moving on from that I want
you to give you a quote and I wanted to
hear what your interpretation of it
would be because it's one that's very
meaningful to me the quality of your
life depends upon the quality of your
thoughts but you are not your thoughts
what would you say that means to you
well I completely agree with it and what
it means for me is well at points
basically - I mean you're going right
here I guess it points to the heart of
the
template of mystery so the the mystery
that's at the heart of the world's
contemplatively shion's and these
traditions are as old as old as
humankind and what they pretty much all
say if you're gonna subscribe to what
they call the perennial espect 'iv which
believes that there is a kind of
convergence and that is only one
perspective there are other perennial
ist's perspective perennial lists
perennialism that basically believes
that there are is a kind of unifying
principle or set of principles that are
there underneath all the world's
practices and traditions and that
they're all trying to sort of point us
there and what they're all trying to
point us to in different ways is that
the limited way in which we experience
ourselves as a kind of mind body
separate from the rest of the world
isolated in this little container is
actually unnecessary it's real it's real
as an experience but there are practices
that can begin to open up the bandwidth
a little bit to allow you to feel
yourself in relationship with a larger
whole and they so they talk I'm not
saying that all these practice
the experience of that is the same and
all these traditions are indeed and all
people it's not I think how its
experienced with in a more Abrahamic
context is that you feel that reality
itself you're in relationship with
reality you're in tune with that it's a
God to you or whatever you want to you
whatever language you want to use
personal that's not that personal God
that's not the language that say a
Buddhist or is used in Indian philosophy
they would say that's your true self
that that you are not your thoughts in
fact what you are from an Indian
perspective of Indian philosophy is the
kind of empty knower of those thoughts
of sounds of all sensations that there's
a process of personality that is you a
mind-body process that's unfolding it
has a history it has preferences and
that's fine
part of path of practices owning that
and creating the best possible by and
braudy process you can if you if you
want to think of it that way but that
it's the awareness of that whole process
that is you the thing that feels like
the center of you the place your knowing
from is actually empty it's the same
in every single human being yeah it's
sort of like an octopus with 6 billion
arms you know and each at the end of
each arm is an eyeball that's looking
out of the world and then we're each of
one of us is one of those arms yeah but
there's only one awareness in that
octopus and that's that I'm giving you
kind of like a boilerplate summary of
how contempo - you know how I kind of
think about it and how a mystic might
describe it and I actually think it's
true insofar as my own experience has
begun to point me in that direction and
if it is true it's [ __ ] mind-blowing
out there talked about by everyone not
just by unhinged mystics because yeah I
think it's as true a description of
human experience and consciousness as
any you'll find in the psychology or
neuroscience literature so I'd agree
yeah I mean the fact that the vast
majority of humans on the planet believe
that they are they are their thoughts as
opposed to the watcher of their thoughts
that there is no distinction between
them and their thoughts is for
neuroscientists contemplatives and
anyone who's done a modicum of
introspective work it's so far off the
mark yeah you know I sorry I just should
say you know I think that as something
we could as a claim of something that's
objectively true about how humans are I
think you can argue with that ok in so
insofar as you could say ok well you
can't argue with is the experience of
suddenly coming out of a thought stream
and being able to notice it so there's
you can't argue with that there's a real
human experience of being able to pen
back the camera and dis embedding from a
particular trance of thinking what you
could say is okay but are you dis
embedding from that trance into just a
broader trance and so a broader view and
so in other words it's thoughts all the
way down which is perfectly legitimate
it actually that is partly been my
experience as an insight practices you
you think you're free and then you
realize that for a while that actually
you're trapped in another kind of layer
and then you pop out again and pop it
again yeah but what's important to me is
not to make any kind of claim about
any kind of objectively quote true to
claim well this works my only interest
in saying it's true as an experience and
as an experience it has great value it
can really help us with our suffering it
can really help us get out of habits of
mind that are very you know disrupted
and so I I'm interested in what's gonna
help people I'm much more interested in
that I'm interested in what's true about
reality so I kind of have to make that
you know you kind of say that in the
world of consciousness studies because
it's you're you're operating in a very
weird and interesting medium you know
it's not quite like other mediums it's a
medium where you know the the
subjectivity itself is kind of changing
what it's learning and what it's
understanding so you have to be kind of
humble about how you talk about that
space because it's also very mysterious
the paradigm and the framework that your
understanding is within is constantly
shifting and the meta fact that the only
way the only way that you can appreciate
my subjective experience is by me
telling you which that you then
subjectively interpret it's like it's
like Inception
it is like Inception I mean which is
actually a fine motion picture yeah I
would say the probably this I mean
there's so many paradoxes in this work
but one of the central paradox is if not
be central is that exploring
consciousness is both a discovery and a
training so you're both discovering
things that are true in your mind like
true dynamics that you're discovering
and saying hey this is the thing I'm
seeing but in the act of seeing it you
are changing what you find so you can
never entirely say are you discovering
something or are you creating it you
know you you can you there's no place
that you can stand in that has with
absolute confidence that could say it's
one or the other and it's probably both
in some way so which i think is good
news for this whole for us in terms of
how in terms of our health in terms of
our happiness because it means that we
can change what we find just my allows
it allows you to build a road towards a
destination which you want
get to and as you're building the road
you learn how to build the road better
and as the road continues along you can
then move forward and back down it
you've seen where you've been you've
laid it and you get a better image of
where you're going in the future
you totally right that as you do your
training the capacity that you have to
move on and your direction becomes more
zeroed in hopefully towards whatever it
is that you're aiming for enlightenment
or self actualization or a better
understanding of the self or wherever
it's heading absolutely that that's true
and then and it's also true that there's
the whole thing is still really shot
through with mystery and surprises and
that you can have an intention you can
have an idea of what you hope will
happen you can be going in a particular
direction but life isn't gonna confirm
itself according to your biases you know
you may have it you may have an idea or
an agenda what's gonna happen but there
it can still go in a different way so
there's a continual dialectic between
you have an intention and that you're
clear about and you and you move forward
and it helps build up a particular kind
of Road but you're also open to the
unexpected and you know that's what
creates actually that's what creates a
lot of wisdom is in that capacity to
kind of hold that that those two things
at once where you're you're moving
forward you're you're deliberate you
know you're building your own reality in
a certain way but you're also humble
enough to know that the thing you're
building is only a small sliver and that
reality itself will have much to say
about it that's a lovely way to put it
so you've touched on the external world
there and I wanted to move on to that as
well so bad things will happen to you
and good things also will inevitably
happen to you how does meditation change
how you're going to feel about them yeah
well again I would say it depends a
little bit on the kind of meditation
that you're doing but the technique that
I'm really sort of most passionate about
I guess or at least I had the most
experience in as a mindfulness technique
and the essence of mindfulness as I see
it is it's really about
dis embedding from trance it's about
coming back to your own awareness and
using that awareness to notice how you
were operating according to a more
limited set of principles and suddenly
you can see a particular thought pattern
a particular way of relating to the
world that you were previously in
unconsciously as you get more experience
with mindfulness you start to see that
that's happening and in the act of
seeing you're no longer in that pattern
so there's a freedom to potentially then
begin to change it so that is
unquestionably enormous a valuable piece
of information to know is liberating
right it's literally
liberating you from the inputs of the
external world to one degree or another
this is not a saying that you're no
longer going to be subject to the forces
of gravity or a car hitting you but this
that your ability to be able to Cory
Allen who I did a podcast with a few
months ago referred to it as the
mindfulness gap which i think is a
lovely way to put it is is how that gap
it's that breadth between something
occurs and your reaction to it or your
thoughts about it
or a thought occurs and your capacity to
not allow the next thought that comes
careering into view to be what do you
think about that you can simply observe
it and watch it go by like cars on a
road or birds in the sky absolutely
that's super well said I mean let's just
unpack that for a second because it is
really really deep and really
interesting what we're talking about
here is you start to learn to live in
that gap so you start to learn to spend
get more and more space around what's
going on in your experience and then at
a certain point you start to realize or
feel that that more spacious place is
more of a true description of who you
are and and the trajectory in a
mindfulness practice I mean we can be
really clear about this that trajectory
in a classic Buddhist mindfulness
practice is happiness independent of
conditions so independent of whatever is
going on in your life whatever horrible
external circumstance is happening
if you can get enough space around it
then you can experience that
circumstance not as a hardship but as
what they would describe as a
purification as another opening to go
deeper into your life and that boggling
to try to consider what that would look
like but that is what the you know I've
done a lot of interviews with lots of
very very very senior teachers and that
more or less is a version of what they
describe and so that's really
interesting and that for me brings up a
lot of questions around first of all do
I want that for myself isn't part of
being in the human experience to be to
be identified to be will that affect
that at all and what they tend to say is
know that you as you get more and more
space around your experience you develop
the option to kind of ride with the
energies of your life in a new way so
there's a kind of bouncy spontaneity and
playfulness that can emerge and it
doesn't say take away from it's not like
you're dissociated when you're dealing
with a tragedy in your life it's more
like the tragedy
instead of being something that's purely
causing suffering is experienced with a
much deeper and raw or sort of poignancy
aesthetic is very deep and meaningful
yes what totally I think the and a nice
analogy there would be the equivalent of
you being in the swell of a wave and it
carrying you into Shore as you're sucked
underneath or you surfing the wave and
allowing the bounce playfulness as you
say the control you are using the waves
of your life but you are in control of
them and you're riding them as opposed
to being carried along at their will I
think it's a like a perfect metaphor and
as someone who serves a lot I love it
because it's true and and actually it's
interesting cuz it sort of says you know
an initial early buddhism it was i mean
some people described early buddhism was
more about okay transcending suffering
you know getting into this place of true
freedom and enlightenment so that you're
you're happy independent of conditions
but then you're also just kind of
chilling out and not really doing much
with those conditions so within Buddhism
they started saying hey you know what's
the point of that we should really be
all about coming back and to try to help
other people and so that became sort of
second wave Buddhism
but then you have sort of third wave
Buddhism within Breton Buddha's and that
was that was saying yeah that's true too
and let's make it about energy and play
and writing that life you know and much
more of a joyful kind of take on it
that's more of a tantric take on it yep
and so I think that's a really I think
that's a really wonderful when we get to
that stuff then it kind of meets the
kind of self-actualization movements
that came out of the West and these
kinds of ideas that there is something
about just you know playing with our
lives and creating those beautiful life
that we can in addition to finding that
freedom that it's both of those things
you're totally right the I use this
analogy with Coryell and I'm gonna use a
game with yourself so do you watch Game
of Thrones oh yeah what's the first few
seasons and love didn't I keep meaning
to try to download it and get the rest
okay I haven't seen the last few seasons
that's fine
so bran who's the young stock he becomes
the three-eyed Raven partway through one
of the seasons I haven't spoiled it for
you I promise and when that happens he
essentially becomes almost completely
detached from all emotion and he's just
like this this Zen master that sat in a
corner but I think that a lot of people
presume if they were to take mindfulness
practice and meditation to its endpoint
that that's what they would become this
kind of turnip that's do you know I mean
that's completely detached from what's
going on around them and I think what's
interesting I can't remember who it was
and I'm gonna butcher the quotes I'll
try and get it get as close to it as I
can that they they said that they
understood that a mindfulness practice
combined with a retention of the ego was
important because the ego is what gives
you the get up and go but it's not being
at the mercy of it that was important
and I think that it's interesting the
dynamic between the ego still being
there and still allowing you to go and
do the things that you want but you
being the person who chooses as opposed
to being at the whim being sucked under
the swell again yeah I think I think
that's the useful way to think of it I
mean I certainly tried to find that
balance in own life I I do want to say
something though about you know I
actually do think that
you know no practice can go on monitors
and there's no such thing as a practice
that you can just implement the
technique and then just be unconscious
in the technique and kind of hopefully
the best you continually need to be
checking in with ways in which a
technique might need to be corrected and
I think in a mindfulness practice
there's definitely a trajectory within a
practice that can happen where people do
get kind of dissociated they do kind of
just get they kind of they become the
kind of witness and everything else is
just passing through them and they're
sort of there is an indifference that
can potentially arise there it's one of
the traps we're gonna practice that a
good teacher should be looking out for
and to help them work through that you
know so it doesn't there is possible to
do a practice and to be it for it to
kind of imbalance you in a new way
so you have to you don't ever get to
kind of lose the response the sense of
responsibility you have to continually
be responsible for where it's taking it
yeah I think that's important to say you
know because I think people have
idealization around practices and that
you definitely hear that a lot with
mindfulness but mindfulness can lead
into some very troubling and challenging
areas so you need to be kind of watching
is this you know you need to always have
a kind of litmus test is this practice
leading me you know am I is my life
better is it leading me is my life
better in the ways that are meaningful
for me to be better you know am i more
connected to my family and friends am I
more creative do I feel like I have more
vitality if it's not doing that then you
may need to make you may need to change
the way you do the practice so yeah I
got a totally are you saying are you
saying that you need to be mindful about
your mindfulness practice yeah it just
keeps going on and on bro yeah oh yeah
you just keep popping oh and happy
mindful at the next level and then you
mindful the next level and like like a
game of whack-a-mole right exactly right
so you touched on something earlier on
about happiness not being contingent on
external factors and there's a lovely
quote from Sam Harris again I'm going to
use now which is that he talks about
solitary confinement being considered as
the worst form of punishment that given
the choice between spending their time
with murderers and rapists or their time
on their own most people would choose
the former but yet solitary confinement
and
and meditation retreats have been used
by contemplatives for thousands of years
to give themselves an insight into the
mind that most normal people can't get I
think that it's that is a perfect
identifier of the fact that is so
contrary to most people to think that
sitting alone with your thoughts would
be beneficial it sounds like a
punishment right absolutely and I mean I
think a lot of people it sounds like a
punishment because for a lot of people
it's experienced that way you know when
I first started meditating it was like
are you kidding me I got to spend all
this time with this guy there's a lot of
really neurotic patterns and suffering
and it was just like being in a hell
spiral so I had you very quickly run in
and but so reporting we're talking about
something really deep here which is that
you know a practice points us to
basically freedom because if what with
you learn that you can't actually just
sit and be with yourself that is a huge
thing to learn about yourself you can't
actually just sit and be okay with
yourself you need to always be changing
the external conditions to be okay
that's a deep unsettled pain or hole in
the middle of your life very unknown or
a evolutionary it it absolutely is very
unnatural so the practice is about you
learn to sit alone so you can actually
be okay with just being with yourself
and as that happens you increase the
exponentially the range of possible
conditions in which you can be free in
it so get it if you're not free in that
situation your constant gonna be
grasping it the next thing you're just
racing from one thing another because
you don't want to spend one second alone
with yourself because it's a horror show
but that is a nightmare to be living
inside and at some point your capacity
to outrace your own aversion to yourself
is gonna fall apart
you know you won't physically be able to
do it you won't find a new knot and
that's what happens we're always trying
to up to novelty at a certain point
there's no greater novelty you can't
find you know once you've done all this
stuff once you've done your Richard
Branson and then all the extreme
experiences and reality and have all the
privileges you know it's something
you're gonna be left with yourself you
better come to peace with it at some
point well we come we come into this
world alone and we leave this world
alone right
there's there's a lovely a lovely little
quote as well that talks about there's
more connections in a single square
centimeter of human brain tissue than
there are stars in the galaxy and you
think that that is a physical
manifestation of the depth of our
experience or the capacity for depth of
our experience and yet you're totally
right that so many people lead a hedonic
life where they're looking for the next
thing that is going to make them happy
there
even when they think that they're
experiencing the present moment that in
very subtle ways they're looking over
its shoulder they're eyeing up what's
coming next even if they think that
they're being present
now you mentioned Shinzon Young who I
know I really want to get onto who is
one of your meditation teachers and he
talks in the science of enlightenment
his book he likens meditation to a magic
trick that can double your life by
increasing the depth of experience I
wondered if you would be able to explain
to people what that actually means and
how that kind of manifests itself
especially moving on from what we've
just talked about there to do with the
the novelty and the chasing the next
thing yeah oh I'm happy to talk about it
I found that to also be true not as I
don't experience it in the way Shinzon
does because he's such a more advanced
practitioner he's an absolute monster
that's like oh yeah he's next level I
mean he's first of all he's in his
mid-70s and he's been hard core
practitioner for 50-plus years and you
know so he's the way he experiences
reality is it's fascinating actually
I've had hundreds of hours of talks with
him about how it is so I may be I'm
sorry it's art you interject if you got
an idea of any idea of how many hours of
practice it's likely that shins and
youngs done during his life that's a
great question I got that ask him I
would guess
I would guess probably upwards of 60,000
hours oh my you know I mean I remember
hearing once about this particular
Tibetan this Tibetan actually I would
guess probably more like 80,000 because
I remember hearing with this Tibetan
teacher who figured out he figured he
was maybe doing it done 65,000 hours of
practice and this guy was my age so he
was in his 40s
condemns in his evidence so your if
people say a hundred thousand hours of
practice is what makes you you know
gives you a certain amount of mastery
you can imagine then compare that so it
definitely is a numbers game the more
time you spend doing it the more time
you spend in awareness the more
awareness erodes everything in your
experience everything just turns into
basically pixelated dust that's how it
all just gets emptied out and turned
into energy so he lives so to go to your
question to why it's deeper I can talk
about in a general way that is
accessible to everyone about that speaks
to my experience and then I can talk
about it in a weird cool [ __ ] up
mystical way that is true of Shinzon
experience and it's really the throwing
focus throw both us it's a it's a
mindfulness spit-roasting it's fine okay
so we're since we're in this roast so
we'll start with the we'll start with
the the dark meat I've had everyone that
everybody likes so so with that I would
say yeah what happens is it's like I
said you begin to feel like you have
more space so you start to see how
previously you're always inside this
sense of urgency sense of urgency sense
of urgency and you were and and the
sense of urgency just gets more urgency
and it baguettes in turn more work and
more complexity and it seems like you're
constantly running at a time but you're
constantly running around this hamster
wheel and it's not even that it stays
the same the more you repeat a loop the
deeper it gets therefore the more it
grows exponentially so you're we're in
these dooms sort of feedback loops of
urgency and limited sense of lovin of a
limitation so as we get into practice we
learn we don't need to feed those loops
and that our space just starts to open
up we realized that actually lots of
things we thought were priorities that
were important that we had to do can
just drop away and the things that are
remained we start to be able to do them
with more intelligence and care and
there's just a sense of overall of like
that you just have more time and space
available in your life and there's a
depth of appreciation that comes from
this too so I often think it's like we
move out of the of a paradigm when we're
trying to you know we're kind of in as
up-and-down paradigm where we're trying
to keep the ups and get rid of the downs
but as you get deeper and
practice like I think I talked about
this in the Prezi skeptics book there's
a depth dimension that comes in so you
you know you can't get rid of the ups
and downs in life entirely although they
may start to round off a little bit with
the practice but what happens is both
the ups and the down start to be
experienced with more poignancy more
fullness and this is where language runs
out this is where the contemporaries
said that they can't explain it you
can't explain what this means but just
that there is a way there are certain
moments that are more poignant and full
and spacious and meaningful and most of
your listeners will know what I'm
talking about but at some time
spontaneously in their life on a nature
hike with a lover who knows what they
entered into a space like that and
that's the space that a deep practice
that meditation practice but many other
kinds of practices can begin to bring us
to so that's what totally dead though so
yeah totally totally yeah so that's what
he means in a general way what I figured
you get it I mean it seems like you
first of all different property it seems
like you do and if you're talking about
modern wisdom I mean it seems the best
fit to the name right if it's the name I
think it's a really good way so one of
the typical co-hosts on the show is a
guy called Yusuf and he gave me this
fantastic insight and I'd be interested
to share it with you and then we'll move
on to the weird quirky insight that
you've got coming up for us what he said
was that the more novel and experiences
the more mindful that we are of it so I
think everyone who's listening will be
able to will be familiar with their days
appearing to go very quickly when you
look back at the last year and you think
well what did I do with my year as every
subsequent year occurs that speed it
appears like you're accelerating right
like you can remember less and one of
the few times where there appears to be
a little bit of a mindfulness gap is
when you do something that's out of the
norm so if the listeners at home can
think about the last time that they went
somewhere new or the last time that they
were driving somewhere in here roadworks
and had to be diverted so the more novel
and experiences
the more mindful that we are of it so
what that means is that the mindfulness
and the understanding of that people can
for instance looking back over my last
year I couldn't really tell you an awful
lot of what occurred during my days when
I went to the office but I went to LA
for 10 days then Hawaii for five Austin
for one in Virginia for six this year
and I can tell you without looking at
notes or a diary every single thing I
did on every single day because the
level of novelty was so high which meant
that my level of mindfulness was so high
so we've shown that in particular
situations we can be significantly more
mindful than we already are
but the beginner's mind or the learned
mind means that when we see things that
we are already familiar with we tend to
allow them to rush past us and we allow
ourselves to be carried off in thought
and not experience the present moment
anymore
I thought that that that example of what
happens when you do something new and
novel was a really good like it's like
taking a quick holiday to mindfulness
land and you go oh that's what it that's
what it feels like that that level of
remembered self and that depth of
understanding and depth of experience
and you know that's that's what it feels
like and I think going to the doubling
your life as Shinzon sites it if I look
back at how fast my holiday went I think
well yeah like I was away for thirty
days but it feels like I was away for 60
days because look at all of the things
that my remembered self can actually
bring into view whereas when I look at a
couple of months stretch where I'm in
the office all the time I think oh my
god that feels like it's gone by in a
week absolutely I could not agree more
yeah that's that's and people describe
that interestingly almost that's almost
a universal description that comes from
practitioners over time of exactly that
kind of an insight
yeah and it's and it's very liberating
you know to to begin to realize that you
can spend more time in that space and
that mindfulness gap as you call it I
mean I would say that it's also partly
it happens because you know when we're
just stuck in our
thoughts were in a much narrower place
as opposed to when were actually popped
out of that and really paying attention
to the richness of what's going on all
around us and that's kind of the
orientation and from that place there's
so much more details to soak in it's
just like when you're having it if
someone's in front of you and they're
kind of here you're half paying
attention to but you're mostly listening
to your own thoughts of what they're
saying you're not taking in what they're
saying you're not taking in the
character in their faces you're not
there's so much information that's not
there so that's why it makes more space
because it brings attention out into the
world where and it's not to say that
it's not important to be able to
sometimes be in your thinking process of
course it's like basically you know
thinking is a wonderful tool it's just a
terrible master you know it's great such
a lovely way to put it but a terrible
master yeah fantastic yeah so um you
saying that there's a slightly more
spooky version a slightly more yeah well
so so so this is where this is something
I'm very interested in which is that the
kind of practice you do shapes your
consciousness in very particular ways
so Shinzon is a classic the possum
honored I mean he's deep he's deeply
shaped by hardcore he passed into
practice from within both a Goenka and a
Mojave tradition and hardcore Zen
practice with him on his teacher and it
would have more of a rinse I practice so
and his main training that he has done
for himself it's in concentration
clarity and equanimity but I would say
in particular in the equanimity and in
the clarity so and in all of them
together but the clarity means that he
spends every moment he's trying to
notice the beginning of each moment he's
trying to hear the very beginning of
each sound he's trying to hear feel the
very beginning of the sensation of
breathing so he has zoomed up the
resolution of his consciousness now so
that he's able to notice the moment
sensory experience begins to emerge into
consciousness most of us there's a kind
of delay but for and there's this
unconscious processing that happens were
underneath the threshold of
consciousness where something stimuli
comes into awareness and then it gets
sort of moved up into the higher levels
of processing and it pops out into into
actual conscious awareness but it
entered the brain earlier and so what
what some meditation researchers
what Shinzon believes and what his
experience describes is that he's slowly
lowered the threshold of his
consciousness down into the the area
where the old turbines are the kind of
under he's in the belly of the beast is
he he's in the valley the beast so he
experiences each moment as that more and
more as that moment begins so his
experience of reality is everything is a
kind of gushing fountain of of energy
that emerges before crystallizes into
any thing where it gets tagged as tree
as person as emotion as thought it's
just this blooming openness of
experience and and he's oriented himself
to the empty space out of which that
bloom arises because if you think about
it like what is the ground of
consciousness you know what is our if
we're looking at we're looking out at
trees and everything but really we're
looking at a TV screen you know all this
is built by our consciousness it's a
model of the world and you can and what
you can realize is that you can in a
sense
turn off the model but there's still a
screen yeah and that's kind of like the
D ground or the emptiness or whatever
you want to call it and some people call
the full version that is awareness when
there's something in it it's aware when
it there's nothing in it it's emptiness
and there's no awareness there's nothing
so he experiences reality as blooming
out of emptiness at every moment and he
knows himself as that emptiness and so
therefore he lives a deathless life well
you wouldn't even begin to imagine what
it's like to experience Shinzon's life
what what it would be like to be him for
five minutes
not really
yes and no like I have had a taste of
some of that because I've done a lot of
practice so I've had experiences like
that maybe not as I so this is the other
thing you realize practice there's a
depth dimension to insight it's like an
iceberg you know and it's always the
same insight it can just ever be deeper
and deeper and deeper deeper yeah so I
have many I've thousands tens of
thousands of times I've had deep
insights into impermanence of insights
into the liberating power of equanimity
of purification I've experienced myself
to be part of this larger process I've
felt myself and merging under the zero
but the way in which I have experienced
that is is super
compared to the way someone like
Shenzhen does because it only gets
deeper with time and I mean it wisdom is
learning from experience so you're
learning new insight is learning from
experience so the longer you are in
experience the more you create that
direction that trajectory of more
openness of more of being in
relationship to the space the more
exponentially quick that grows just like
a bad habit grows and eventually you're
inside something that's so foreign to
where it what you were when you began
and yet you can see that it's the same
principle operating all the way through
is that does that make sense
totally totally get it I think one thing
that I'd love to get your thoughts on is
the difference between state and trait
changes that occur within meditation I
discuss this with Corey Allen and I've
discussed it at length with a number of
my friends who are significantly more
experienced meditation practitioners
than I am but I think a lot of people
expect the trait changes to manifest
themselves
my 30-day course and then I'm not going
to feel anger anymore or I'm gonna be
completely immune to your negative
emotions or I'm just gonna have this
blissful happiness all the time and it's
I think reminding people to focus on the
state changes how it feels when they
meditate as opposed to the Brandon Stark
turn up in the corner and again I think
it's good to to focus on that and I
wondered if you had any thoughts about
the state versus trait changes there cuz
ya fulness ya know I think a lot about
it I think I mean ultimately so I think
of it as three levels I think of it as
state it starts a state then it goes
into trade then it goes to state entry
so and so basically I think of
meditation is it's sort of it's
something that happens at three
different times in in the same moment
you could say so there's the there's the
in the moment experience of meditation
where you sit down and you pay attention
your breaths and it can almost many
techniques can start to create a
temporary state change right there you
can start to feel more calm your anger
can start to be metabolized you can go
into the states of bliss of whatever you
can take create a state change that's
how that's that's
as it unfolds in the moment but then you
have practice as it unfolds over months
and years and that's what's that's what
generates the trait change so you do you
practice being more friendly for example
and you can start to feel more friendly
as a state change in the moment and over
time doing that more and more the
default baseline of friendliness starts
to increase
so the trait of friendliness starts to
become easier and easier to get and
that's the second so that's the and
that's really what we're looking at in a
meditation practice is looking at the
scale of months and years there's a
scale the moment that it makes me feel
better in the moment sure I can do that
or I can actually be make you feel worse
in the moment sometimes because
meditation doesn't always go easily but
over the long run it begins to create
those state changes now there's also a
third scale and that's the scale of a
lifetime and that's really what the deep
end of practice is about the deep end
the practice is pointing you towards the
whole of your life to beginning to
experience yourself as a larger whole
beginning to feel yourself in
relationship to the whole of your life
that's kind of the deep meaningful stuff
and when that as that starts to come
really online you have a combination of
the state and the trait where this that
trait becomes so well entrenched that
you get you you're more likely to be in
that state all the time yeah maybe not
now 24/7 at Shenzhen would say the small
self always comes back you know you
still they're always gonna be times when
you're gonna fall out of that when
you're gonna get into you know you're
gonna forget yourself and get into a
more limited pattern of reactivity or
whatever but then you pop out of it
again and the the time you spend in that
more spacious place just gets bigger and
longer over time so this is it does that
is that is that helpful that's driving
it totally get it yeah so going back to
the individual practices what your
thoughts on guided versus on guided
meditation practices I think it's really
users choice so some people I think
especially for a beginner it can be
really helpful to have that orientation
I mean mindfulness means remembering
it's sati it's remembering to be aware
of what's going on and it's very easy
you start a meditation with the best of
intentions you start paying attention
your breath and then you know five
minutes later
you're thinking about you know who knows
what so having a guided structure where
the the guide is kind of bringing you
back online is super helpful for a lot
of people but for other people they find
it distracting they're able to generate
enough of that mindfulness on their own
or nothing whatever they need so I would
say you know I think there's a there's
definitely a place for both for me I
still listen to guided practice
sometimes because I find it helpful but
I also really enjoy not listening to
guided practices so I would be both so
is it does it feel a little bit like
training wheels yeah yeah for sure and
then removing removing the the training
removing one removing two sometimes
putting them back on etc etc yeah I mean
it is a little bit like that
it's a structure it's a support
structure that's there for the for you
at the beginning but it's no there
there's nothing wrong with needing his
support structure you know and some
people may need that for a very long
time others may feel like okay at a
certain point I want to lose that
support structure and see what happens I
would encourage people to try to do that
because we are talking about trying to
be you know good in all conditions so if
the condition of having a support
structure is the only way you meditate
at some point you might want to
experiment with losing it but if doing
that leads you into a storm of thinking
then put the we put the wheels back on
it's no shame you know it's just about
what works I totally get that there's a
an app that I know Youssef will be
shouting at his earphones at the moment
saying I need to mention it called
insight timer and it's just that it's
literally that it's a it's a time of the
use on your phone however one of the
things that it can do is you can set it
to have a little that very quiet knock
on wood at specific intervals throughout
so I got that every minute every two
minutes every five minutes and that is
what he uses to bring himself back to
the breath and to just it's just a
little tap in the back of the head going
and make sure that you thinking about
the right thing excellent that's funny I
do I use inside time for the exact same
way
I know exactly that wouldn't block that
use of uses it's the best little poke a
little talk sound you kind of like yep
brings you back yeah I was thinking
about my dinner again or I was thinking
about work again or I was lost in
thought so would you advise people to
get a meditation
teacher you know it's evident from
hearing you speak today and also from
reading your other bits online that
shins and Young's had an incredibly
profound effect on yourself
is there a after a particular number of
years of practice should someone look to
get a teacher is it something that
everybody could do with from the
beginning can you talk us through what a
meditation teacher does and and how it
can benefit people yeah sure
well I think I what I would say is the
most important thing is that
occasionally having and being able to
check in with somebody about your
practice so being able to get another
perspective on what's happening even if
you're the most resolutely independent
person we in a practice a meditation
practice is is still another habit and
sometimes we can develop habits that are
actually not serving us so we can get
stuck in a kind of cul-de-sac so we
might be in a state of kind of low-level
checked out drooly bliss and we think
that that's what it's all about but
we're actually still a complete dick in
our life or we're still hung up in all
these other ways so the great benefit of
a teacher it's really the benefit of
having another perspective hopefully a
knowledge knowledgeable perspective that
can hear about your practice and give
you some feedback so you can kind of
reorient that's I think I think that is
important for everybody whether it's a
formal teacher relationship I don't
think it needs to be like I am a big
thing with I mean it was very valuable
for me and I think it's very good to
start out at least with a teacher who
can kind of get you going and answer
some of the the main questions but I'm a
big champion of the community as the
teacher you know that's what that's one
of the mantras of what we say it the
consciousness was borås Club we
deliberately created a kind of non
hierarchical culture where we respect
the fact that there is a genuine such a
thing as deepening an experience so
there's more expertise and less
expertise around a particular technique
and people who've been at it longer have
a lot to share but that no matter who
you are it's valuable if you can be
honest with what's going on in a
particular way in which you're
addressing some situation or challenge
then you're creating insights for other
people and that we
and so you can you can you can sit with
a group of friends and you can meditate
it and you can share about your
experience and you can learn a lot about
how to work with what's going on and
that can be that other perspective I'm
talking about to be able to do that once
in a while but at the same time I think
it's you know if you're gonna take it
seriously I think it's very valuable to
be able to check in with somebody who
genuinely has a lot of deep experience
even if it's just their experience
because here's another thing here's
another one of those cool paradoxes or
again we talk about the nature of wisdom
wisdom is learning from experience we
can we're all learning our unique things
about experience that may be different
within what other people are learning
and we can pull our wisdom that way
absolutely so there's a pluralistic
sense in which that's how is deMunn
Cold's but there's also this miss other
dimension to experience I would call or
a to wisdom and experience capital w
wisdom and that is that the longer you
practice certainly for me as a teacher
the longer I practice the more people I
speak to the more people I work with the
more I start to get clear and clear
intimations of what seems to be true for
all people and that's what Dharma means
Dharma means truth so it's it's talking
about the wisdom the progeny ax that is
the dynamics that are that seem to be
true for everyone do you know the right
unity across everything and that right
so that's moving towards a unifying or
an absolute direction so so you need to
have that perspective I think it's
really helpful to that perspective in
this world as well where you have
teachers that have that have been
practicing for twenty thirty years that
have that are able to articulate what
they can what they see is is universal
and experience and that's what when you
go to a good teacher but a non-dual
teacher of Buddhist teacher whatever it
is and you have that they say something
there's that quickening you're like [ __ ]
man it just hit you right in the belly
that's what you're getting you're
getting that that deep truth and that's
a real thing oh yeah that's the that
thing is the thing that people come for
people say oh yeah I'm here I come for
the stress I come in focus I want to be
less angry yeah maybe they come for that
they stay for this stuff because this
stuff is the the stuff they really feel
it's the magical mystery tour or what
the [ __ ] 'no some reality where you're
dropping into this leg into these deep
truths that you the hairs were I rise up
in the back of your neck that's what I'm
talking about
I totally get it it's there's a cool
quote from Johann Wolfgang von Goethe
that says all truly wise thoughts have
already been thought a thousand times
but to make them truly ours we must
think them over again honestly until
they take root in our personal
experience and I think that's one of the
problems that's one of you oh you like
that one yeah that was amazing
so I think that's one of the reasons why
people's lives don't change when you see
an inspirational quote on Instagram if
with that without context or by in even
the most enlightening concepts don't
resonate with us and what we need is we
need we need that that experience we
need to to have that resonation between
us and the concept and that's that's
where it like you say is it's such a
good analogy for it that punching you in
the stomach and it sort of swells inside
of you and it's that [ __ ] like like how
didn't I see this before and I think
that's the analogy that the guys from
headspace use Andy podium talks about
this a lot about the mind being like the
sky and I love this one and he says that
your mind is you are the sky and
everything else is the weather that the
weather can come and go and that it can
be cloudy it can be rainy but that above
the clouds the Sun is always there and
all that needs to happen is that the
clouds need to disperse and the Sun
comes back again but the Sun doesn't
leave when the clouds are there it's
just the fact that you can't see it and
exactly that was that was a punch in the
stomach moment for me for sure when I
heard that and yeah that's what that's
what Tibetans call natural mind or that
the the and the belief within Buddhism
is that the natural state of the mind
actually is a state of openness of
creativity of peace scent it's just this
broad spacious vibrant place that gets
covered over with what they call the
clashes or various pains and obsessions
and the ways in which we get caught up
in the small trance of our life and not
see that bigger picture perspective
but just it can I just come back comment
on one thing you said a moment ago about
you know people here something that it's
like they hear a bit of wisdom they hear
an insight and it's a great quote and
it's like boom there's this moment where
it resonates I think yeah I feel that
and then of course you go back to your
life and they say so that's why I say a
quote most the time a super insightful
quote may not stay and the reason it
doesn't stay is because you haven't made
it your life yet you know and that's
what and there are times when we hear a
phrase or a word and then they call it
turning words where somebody or it's
also described sometimes it's pointing
out destruction instructions somebody
describes something in a particular way
and it is so it just shoots through all
your guards so totally vividly true that
it lands in your belly and sometimes so
deeply that it does create a permanent
change right there so the listeners at
home I promise that we haven't actually
rehearsed this but Jeff I'm looking at a
court in front of me from Jay Kristoff
which says an avalanche starts with one
pebble all you need is the right one
totally totally it's so cool I mean this
stuff I just think it's fascinating I
love it like I don't know like I feel
like it's the biggest privilege in the
world to be able to talk to you about it
to be able to see I mean you share a
practice and you start to see people's
life's change but behind that is this
fact that you're exploring this mystery
of being a human being and the mystery
is way bigger than anything that we know
in any one little domain or silo of
knowledge and then we can be
participants in this mystery you know
and we can we can it's not because
that's what happens in a practice you it
starts as a bunch of ideas but you start
to live these truths you start to live
this stuff and then you just can't even
believe that this is happening so we're
all lawyers right we're all mopping the
terrain together man that's how I feel
I agree um so I wait to do a couple I
get a couple of more insights from you
um you talk a lot about the pooling of
wisdom and the democratizing the sharing
of practice can you explain what you
mean by that
yeah so it's partly what I was saying
about the community is the teacher it's
understanding that when you're honest
when you're actually honest and real
about your experience you are embodying
that direction that that's spacious more
absolute more wisdom direction yook and
you have an enormous amount that you'll
be so every one of us can do this every
one of us can be honest about our
experience and when we do that we're
teachers to each other so it's sort of
in a way it's it's trying to
decentralize and/or democratize the idea
of the teaching so it doesn't have to
only be the lofty teacher on the
pedestal we can recognize that we all
have something to provide on what it is
to be human so it's partly that but it's
that and I I'm interested in that in the
service of really opening up the guiding
and sharing and meditation practices
because I basically see a major mental
health crisis happening as a lot of
people do right now where levels of
stress and mental illness I mean it's
all off the charts and we don't have
enough meditation teachers like who've
spent like Shinzon 50 years in a
monastery to able to kind of meet each
one of those those people so we need to
start empowering many more practice
groups to be out there and they need to
be able to be it's okay to have an
amateur practice group it's more
important to have an amateur practice
group with amateur teachers than to be
not practicing and teaching at all and
so I'm really interested in what is the
minimum people and groups need to know
to be able to safely share meditation
minimum effective dose so speak the
minimum effective dose but also the
minimum way to how to do it safely and
effectively because there is a lot of
because even as I'm saying this there's
a lot of stuff coming out now about what
people would call the dark side of
mindfulness or and what you know which
is there's a few things there but it's
gonna say what's up well there's a two
main things there one of the things is
one of the things is very rare and it
has to do is when you go really into
hardcore deep practice you and you're
deconstructing reality you can end up in
these sort of dissociated states and you
can you can cause really you can do that
in a reckless way so if you're gonna do
that kind of practice you absolutely
need senior level teachers to guide you
is that when you turn into a turnip
uh it could be a turnip or it could be
that you turn into like a vibrating bolt
of electricity and it will happen to me
and the energy has go off for months you
know got you so there's that kind of
stuff but then there's I would say a
much broader more relatable set of
potential challenges has to do with what
we're learning about trauma which is
that you know trauma is kind of a big
word you could think of it as there are
shocks that the nervous system
experiences that are not so much that
are very different for each person and
that sometimes when we and they they
leave these kind of undischarged
energies of fight and flight and who
knows what neurotic stuff in our bodies
and sometimes when we go into stillness
with a meditation practice all that
stuff can rear its head and sometimes
the instructions with the simple
mindless instructions aren't enough to
deal with that we may actually need to
seek some kind of professional support
in a different modality so so all that
is to say my interest is in like I want
to empower everyone to begin to think
about how to share practices in a safe
way so parents can share them with their
kids so friends can share them with each
other you know it can become something
that the whole world is doing in their
own way in a way that's responsive to
the local needs but I want to do it in a
safe way too so what is the minimum that
needs to be imparted for that to happen
and that's that's a book I'm working on
right now that's a of course I'm going
to an online course I'm going to roll
out as an in-person course in Ottawa I'm
doing it in October and I'll start to
offer them in a lot more places but
that's so that's what I that's kind of
my interest my interest isn't okay I
want to help the planet you know have
better more centered self regulation
more mental health habits right now we
see meditation as this sort of
specialist thing but actually I think
the basic understanding of the mind and
self-regulation is as fundamental as a
basic understanding of diet and of
exercise and that we need to be teaching
this to our kids we need to be it needs
to be in schools it needs to be and I
don't mean that's only mindfulness I
mean that understanding of mind body I
mean an understanding of all practices a
ways of exploring practices talking
about what practice is so that's what I
am pointing to with all that I told each
other I think
there's baggage that comes along with
mindfulness unfortunately or comes along
with the term of meditation and
increasingly now a meditation is a it's
an incredibly secular act right you know
it's it's there's not that you don't
have to subscribe to any sort of
theology that comes attached with it
although some people choose to weights
based on my my friends and my exposure
to it the vast majority of people don't
they treat it the same way as you'd
treat a gym you wouldn't say oh well I'm
a I'm a weightlifting church person and
you go no no no I just I just do
weightlifting it which allows me to
achieve the goals of weightlifting and I
think you touched on something that's
really interesting they're talking about
people on earth thing bad experiences or
there's an analogy or a experiment that
was done that was trying to work out why
people in the mid-fifties
in the sort of mid 80s and 90s were
experiencing what appeared to be
spontaneous
LSD trips and what had happened was the
Summer of Love in the 60s when everyone
had been taking LSD LSD can actually be
deposited in fat cells in the body then
as people got into their 30s maybe got
got married with kids they started to
gain weight and this LSD was deposited
into the fat cells then if these people
lost weight
later in their 50s it would then get re
deposited back into the bloodstream so
some poor poor mom of three might be
walking down the street to the go to the
shops and get hit with a couple of
micrograms of LSD that she took thirty
years ago and that resurgence of a
traumatic experience kind of feels a
little bit similar to what you were
talking about there and a podcast I did
with Susanna Hallinan who's a positive
psychologist I asked her a really
interesting question and I said is
making someone happy the same as making
someone not sad and she said no they're
two very distinct approaches and the
reason is it would appear what you're
talking about here that dealing with
trauma and improving normality are two
different approaches and the
introspective work for someone who has
got a lot of trauma to deal with can
actually be a very dangerous thing that
that they should be there should be some
trepidation about doing and MILCON
honestly I'm bouncing around ideas here
on the notes as I go through it you
touched on the fact that you think that
there's a global or a widespread mental
health epidemic so to speak that's
coming do you think that this is an
analogy that could be drawn to kind of
like global warming here that we need to
have the tools to be able to fix the
problems that are a byproduct of modern
society and that those need to be rolled
out essentially rolled out more quickly
than they are yeah I mean I absolutely
think that I mean I think that the
precondition to solving the world's
external problems is to have a more
optimal internal condition set of
conditions and that I mean the classic
quote is you can't change the world's
problems with the consciousness that
created them and that people been saying
that for years
and that a big part of so it's like yeah
there's all these external challenges
and now they're in the ecosystem and
it's very very serious but if we come at
those challenges with the same
obsessions and biases and fixations and
propensity for conflict and reactivity
then we're just going to create more
noise in the system and more we're gonna
potentially just make it worse and that
much more much much improvement on that
model would be to come at those
questions from a place of relative
sanity and clarity and openness and
genuine genuine openness to
collaboration where your capacity to
listen we are not just in your obsessive
trance and so I think that that's I mean
from my mind
a kind of training and how to be in the
mind and how to have a mind and how to
be in relationship is essential for
everyone because it's what's gonna allow
us to have the best chance to address
all the external stuff I mean it's there
is a direct correlation you refer to it
I think on your website as personal
hygiene inter personal interpersonal
hygiene personal hygiene interpersonal
hygiene which i think is a lovely way to
put it and it touches obviously on
something
everybody does or thankfully the vast
majority of people do and treating it as
a must do not I should do is probably
what feels to me like the best way to go
about this so what's your what's your
sentiment at the moment about the
trajectory of the mindfulness movement
right now are you are you hopeful do you
is it a we at crisis periods sort of
where's your head out with it ah I mean
I I mean I may have a slightly different
perspective on it other people like I
kind of take the big-picture view you
know I think it's I think it's great to
me that there's a big explosion of
interest in mindfulness just like I
think it's great that there's been a big
explosion of interest in yoga I think I
what I see across the board is there's
just more interest in practice and
people beginning to take responsibility
for themselves and people realizing the
value and importance of these self-care
practices whether it has to do with body
practices diet practices mind practices
there's a mean compared to the kind of a
there's so much more consciousness
around this now than there was 50 years
ago you know ever it's on everyone's
thinking and talking about these kinds
of things so that's the trajectory I
look at and I think it's a great thing
that that's happening whether within
mindfulness itself of course within that
there are going to be people who are
able to I mean there's going to be a
very let's say that there's different
levels of other ways in which those
mindfulness is being taught and being
disseminated and that some people can be
emphasizing parts of mindfulness that
may not be that can be a little bit
reckless or or you know and there's
things you could criticize about in a
small picture of whether this is this is
really the best thing for here I mean
for example there's a kind of as soon as
mindfulness gets big all of a sudden it
becomes the big panacea now it's gonna
be the answer to everyone's problems and
everyone's talking about mindfulness
it's you can get mindful mayonnaise
mindful you have you know mindful
whatever like classes on mindful like
long trimming yeah it's just like
and so and what happens then well first
of all people are making way too many
claims for it because it's not magic you
know in a way and what you just said
there is say you come across major
traumatic symptoms Michaels can really
help with a lot of that it can also
exasperate them so it's not it needs to
be done in tandem with other modalities
you know in certain situations
and so there's and so you know that's
and that's just true and then and then
and then there's some the ways in which
you could actually be genuinely reckless
like you get into doing in a serious
mindfulness practice if you have a lot
of those undi stabilizations already you
can make make things worse so there has
to be some thinking around that as well
it needs to be done responsibly then I
suppose these be done responsibly needs
to be seen is just like there are it's
another tool in the tool belt it's great
there are other things that are great
too but at the same time you also don't
want to be like it's also very easy for
there to be a backlash and already
seeing that too because everyone here is
mindfulness everywhere people think I'll
[ __ ] I know what this is my bliss is
stupid I'm just annoyed by it or just
because you're a you know because you
get or you're just a reactive dude
you're like screw that I'm definitely
I'm not gonna look at this at all
now all suave people aren't even looking
at my voice but I think they know what
mindfulness is yeah because it's so
simple
oh just bringing stuff into awareness
which is part of it but they're not that
doesn't get it the whole crazy [ __ ] that
I just spent the entire you know
explaining about yeah there's a ton of
amazingly deep stuff in mindfulness but
but you know people hear the word so
much after a while they go unconscious
on the word mindfulness they get on
mindfully mindless and start to think
they know what it is yeah so there's all
kinds of ways in which you know but
that's it in terms of the big picture I
guess I see it as God in the devil neck
and neck you know it's like one start to
get ahead then the next one pulls ahead
and the next one pulls ahead so I see
the interest in taking responsibility
for ourselves the interest in
self-regulation and practice as being a
deeply positive force in society and
culture maybe the most positive thing
that's happening but at the same time
things are [ __ ] up exponentially all
around this you know the the
environments going to hell in a
handbasket
you know mental illness is shooting up
the Richter scale you know there's Wars
breaking out we got
Donald [ __ ] Trump in the US
who's just complete [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ] if you don't agree with me
it's just like what the [ __ ] yeah what
the hell's going on so it's like which
is gonna which of those things is gonna
win I don't know I mean I think it's
just like as we get more awareness the
stakes are always increasing
my sense is it may not always just keep
going on that trajectory and there's
just always gonna be more intensity but
always be more capacity for spaciousness
around that intensity and there's no
Disneyland ending there's just ongoing
continuous complexity until we either
destroy ourselves or or who knows yeah
that's a that's a lovely way to round it
up there for anyone who is a little bit
more interested in having an alternative
view of global warming there's a podcast
that I did a few weeks ago with
Professor Adam Frank where he talks
about global warming essentially being a
natural byproduct of any world girdling
civilization and I think that this this
race toward a lot of the things that
we've gone through on the individual
level it seems like we can get good
control but on the societal level and on
a broader scale that's when that's when
things can start to become bastardized
so for instance you've got there's a
move towards mindfulness but what that
means is there's now a market for
mindfulness and inevitably wherever
there's a market there's money to be
made which means that charlatans will
appear which means that people will
promote practices we're very responsible
and the same thing goes for global
warming in psyche well agricultural
revolution was fantastic Industrial
Revolution was fantastic but very
quickly we overshoot and in the same way
that a light bulb is supposed to give
off light which we won but it also gives
off heat which we don't want there's all
of these weird byproducts and extra
things ancillary bits that get tagged on
the side and that's where the [ __ ]
occurs right like that's where the
actual bad things happen I totally agree
I mean there's a great maybe the one of
the last things to share with your with
your Posse there there Mike Shinzon has
this great expression he talks about
waxy buildup and and so and it's
basically how he describes how
reactivity builds so though people say a
relationship so you're new to a
relationship you're completely in love
and everything they do
is perfect you know it's like they do no
wrong and then you know a year into a
relationship you kind of noticed that
they chew with their mouths open a
little bit and it's kind of annoying
they get a little bit annoyed then
you're like yeah that's okay they're
still cute I love them whatever and then
it's like three years down the road and
now it's like you know every time they
eat that just like they're greeting Ani
the same like chewing oh my god whatever
and then before long as ten years down
the road and there's just been this
build up and build up and build up a
little bit of reactivity building on
itself and at some point they just open
their mouth to eat a hamburger and then
you're just like [ __ ] it and we're
getting a divorce I'm done and for in
your in your view they're just the
Antichrist the whole relationship is
transformed it it's because it was lots
of it was like a death by a thousand
cuts it increases in aggregates over
time and that's all of us are in that
dynamic where we're getting a little bit
reactive about the things happening
around us and then we get a little bit
more react a little bit more reactive
that just builds and that is right it
compounds and that's the same dynamic
that happens globally it happens
socially that happens culturally we have
you know a conservative can't even hear
a liberal begin to speak or vice versa
before they're already in a massive
emotional storm you know they don't even
they can't and they'll capacity even to
listen to what each other is saying and
in the same way within the climate
debates and everything else there's just
and even though I'm I consider myself
politically very progressive I do I see
this as a problem that happens across
all political divides all social them
I'm not sure he's so tribal right like
yeah it's the it's an unintended
consequence of something that kept us
alive for a long time that this still
this desire a tribal but the tribe we
can't see around is the tribe of our own
individual biases you are in your own
tribe the tribe of one you know and you
are you create this whole carapace of
biases that are basically warping how
you interact with the world around you
and you think you're just being this
neutral actor we're all like that and so
that's what I mean the practice is about
beginning to dismantle that carapace so
we can actually have true intimacy in
connection with each other you know we
can we're not just bumping up against
each other like you know you know cars
and one of those you know those amusing
parts of the little bumper cars yep yep
that's none of what it's like and it's
instead let's just have a giant group
man because it's all about love giant
car oh gee giant car orgy no we mean
fantastic gently melt our cars that
sounds good
Jeff would you be able to tell the
listeners at home where they can find
you online please if they want to check
out your guided meditations or read some
Moria stuff my website is Jeff Warren
dot org or our g so as je FF w AR re n o
RG and I got tons of stuff there like a
actually just put out a new online
course like literally like two days ago
the first one I've ever done so it kind
of it's called the elements of practice
or elements of meditation okay
and I have lots of writing up there and
then the other one is I would say CEC
meditate calm so that's the
consciousness explorers club and there's
a ton of free meditations there there's
resources oh and by the way I wouldn't
mind saying this I'm just putting the
finishing touches on version one of the
Maya community prep kind of practice
startup kit so it's like 15 pages how
about anyone anywhere it can start up
their own little practice group it's
sort of along the lines of what I was
talking about some best practices know
how to do it safely what some of the how
to work with different challenges and
that should be free that'll be in the
next CC newsletter and it'll be in one
of mine next newsletter so if you sign
up for those you can get that and it's
no strings attached there's no money no
not the cc's in nonprofits so we were
actually a registered nonprofit so
fantastic well I'll make sure that the
link to everything is in the show notes
below meditation for fidgety skeptics
will be in there the head trip will be
in there as well all of the stuff that
we've gone through there's a really cool
study which I actually send to you as
soon as we get off the air which
explains a from an analytical
perspective the experience the
differences in experience of life at 50
hours a hundred hours 500 hours a
thousand five thousand and ten thousand
hours of practice to really really
interesting read for anyone who wants to
start to understand the trajectory of
mindfulness practice a little bit more
and maybe begin to get a sense of what
shins and younger understands on a daily
basis but Jeff it's been an absolute
blast man thank you so much for coming
on I'm excited to see what you do is you
move forward consciousness explorers
club I'm deaf
gonna check that out and yeah it's it's
been awesome on thank you awesome Chris
it was my pleasure and there's all kinds
of awesome insights emerged from from
you so I I'm glad you're doing this
podcast for folks I appreciate that
thank you very much have a good day man
okay bye
[Music]